we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a voicemail about whatever
happened to that payroll tax cut david
calling from texas no one's talking
about
the fact that the republicans are not
doing the payroll tax cut
right now that they're not for it right
in my opinion
is because they know once joe biden is
confirmed
as president should he get the
nomination
that he is going to do the payroll tax
cut and
the blood will be on the democrats hands
i'm not so sure about that
i think republicans are in favor of the
payroll tax cut
but they recognize that there's a good
chance
nothing happens if that becomes the
sticking point i also am just not sure
that joe biden is going to do it so i
i'm interested in the way in which the
payroll tax cut stuff has imploded on
trump
but i don't know that i agree with this
particular analysis but let me know what
you think is this caller on to something
we've got a great bonus show for you
today russia's looking to approve
a coronavirus vaccine within weeks
according to a new report
trump's looking at banning tick-tock in
the united states and we will talk about
the lack of resources for a lot of
people who want to vote by mail
what do i mean by that we will discuss
it get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show